NATHEN HARVEY:
Next 2019 included
so many great sessions.
It is likely you missed
a few or wanted to relive
some of your favorites.
My friend Seth Vargo
gave an awesome talk
about DevOps vs. SRE.
Are they competing
standards or friends?
Join me for a spoiler-free
preview of Seth's presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Developers are told to build
and ship features faster.
Operators are told to keep the
system stable and reliable.
This creates an environment
with misaligned incentives.
This misalignment
encourages developers
to throw changes over the
proverbial wall as fast
as possible, while
encouraging operators
to reject those
changes in pursuit
of stability and reliability.
Shipping faster and running
more reliable systems
are great objectives.
But the DevOps movement
is about more than that.
It's about aligning everyone
to improve the customer
experience.
There are a number
of DevOps practices
that we can put
in place to help.
Let's take a quick
look at some of them.
First up is the
idea that we should
reduce organizational silos.
Developers and operators
working together
are more capable of
delivering the best results.
We all want to live
in a world where
our systems are 100% available,
reliable, and performant.
We also know that this land
of unicorns and lollipops
does not actually exist.
DevOps implores us
to accept failure
as a normal mode of operation.
Something we can do to
improve both speed and safety
is implement and introduce
changes gradually.
Deploying a small
change that was made
is much safer than deploying
a large change that
was made and has been building
up over a number of weeks
or even months.
Another practice of
DevOps is leveraging
tooling and automation.
Whether provisioning systems,
deploying applications,
or patching the
operating system,
there is a place for good
automation practices.
Making these tasks
easy and automatic
frees up developers,
operators, and others
to focus on more important work.
Finally, DevOps teaches us that
we need to measure everything.
Having good metrics and
measurements about our systems
helps us make good
decisions about how
to improve those systems.
Without good
metrics, how will we
know if our changes
were impactful?
So those are some of
the DevOps practices.
What, exactly, is SRE?
Well, in 2016, Google,
together with O'Reilly,
released a book on the topic of
site reliability engineering.
The ideas presented
in the book have
led some to ask the question
that is central to this talk--
are DevOps and SRE
competitors or friends?
One concept that SRE
introduces is the error budget.
It helps the business
make trade offs
between speed and reliability.
The error budget informs what
to do when the system is not
meeting its reliability goals.
For example, the
error budget may
dictate that teams stop
pushing new features
and focus all
engineering efforts
on the things that make
the system more reliable,
like automated deployments.
SRE provides a framework for
defining these error budgets.
We start with service
level indicators, or SLIs.
An SLI is a metric that tells
us something about the system.
The best SLIs are
the ones that give us
an indication of
customer happiness.
So for example, a
customer will be happy
when their shopping cart loads
correctly and unhappy when
it loses items.
From the SLIs, we can now
generate some service level
objectives, or SLOs.
An SLO lets us set a goal for
an acceptable level of service
reliability over time.
For example, we might say
that 99.99% of requests
to the shopping cart
over the past 28 days
should be successful.
So DevOps and SRE--
are they competing
standards or friends?
Well, I promise not
to spoil it for you.
So check out the link
in the description below
to find out the answer, or
draw your own conclusions.
And while you're there,
be sure to subscribe
to the Google Cloud
YouTube channel for more
great Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]